the Joe Rogan experience I'm hoping so
much of what comes out of this is a
wake-up call so much of the the newfound
understanding and appreciation for the
science behind dealing with these
diseases appreciation of healthcare
workers and first responders I mean if
there's any bright lining to this that's
what I'm really hoping for is that
people wake up and and recognize the
good work that people like you have been
doing and also you know that this is
where we live in strange times and these
things can happen again and we need to
be prepared and we need to put a lot of
emphasis and effort and thought to that
as a whole as a whole society right
that's right I think you know maybe this
will help us reassess some of our values
and and you know appreciate some of the
some of the things that the health care
professions especially are doing and you
know you're seeing people volunteer you
know they're going right you know right
into the belly of the beast you know
people you know who might have
subspecialty practices they said the
hell with it I'm just gonna put on my
n95 mask and my PPE and dive in and help
and that's really moving why have there
been such a shortage of masks and safety
equipment for healthcare workers and how
did this ever happen well we just we
didn't get ready for the surgeon time
and I think you know I think you know I
I'm sort of holding back trying to throw
stones at this this agency or this
person or this group because we don't
really know what happened I think it's
going to be really important that
Congress after this and conduct an
investigation not from the standpoint of
prosecuting people or or calling them
out but just say hey what the hell went
wrong here and and how do we avoid this
again I mean the problems with the
testing and not having all the
protective equipment now we're getting
geared up in mobilizing industry but
what could we have done better
especially in that window period when
things were collapsing in wuhan and the
other cities in central China
when we knew this was going to be bad
and we knew this could become you know
one of the great pandemic threats you
know why how could we have better used
those six weeks and in order to get
ready and what didn't we do and and and
now's not the time to do it because
though the last thing you want to do is
start distracting people and worrying
about you know congressional hearings
and and and that sort of thing but when
all this is said and done it has to be
it has to be done the right spirit not
again we have to figure out a way to
stop these partisan lines to say there
was as a country we've got to figure out
the work together that sounds
pollyannish but you know when I was in
you know before I moved to Texas a
decade ago I was chair of microbiology
at George Washington University for for
ten years and I worked with Congress a
lot to get legislation passed around
neglected tropical diseases and it was a
different Washington than I mean I would
go you know to sam Brownback's prayer
breakfast sam Brownback's governor of
kansas before we senator from Kansas
very conservative Republican senator
walk across the hall and go talk to
Senator Leahy's people from Vermont or
sherrod Browns people and you know it's
far far to the left and nobody thought
any twice about that you know we all
knew we ought to go across the aisle to
work together and it's just not
happening anymore nuts and it's tearing
a part of our country so I hope the
other thing that we get out of this is
figuring out a way that Republicans
start talking to Democrats again and
Democrats talk to Republicans again and
figure that out as well
[Applause]